what's going on everybody it's warren
and welcome back to the cosmic wonder
where we talk all things marvel and mcu
and today we're going to be talking
about something that i know a lot of
people are going to be very very
interested in you may have heard about
it going around online but there is a
supposed leaked description for the
second spider-man no way home trailer
the trailer that everybody is waiting
for and some details have been revealed
that give us a little bit of an insight
of why the trailer may not have been
released yet we're almost within a month
of the actual movie's release and we
still haven't gotten an official trailer
for it so a lot of us are wondering what
the heck
what's your question my question is what
the hell but the rumor going around of
why it hasn't been released yet is
actually a pretty good one and pretty
interesting and i would like to hear
your thoughts on this in the comments
after i go over it and to top it all off
we could have the run time for spiderman
no way home that could have possibly
been revealed then of course i'll talk
about all of this in this video if
you're here you probably love spider-man
which means you'll probably love our
giveaway given away a spider-man action
figure by variant bring arts there is
one day left we are picking a winner and
announcing a winner tomorrow all you
have to do to enter subscribe to my
channel and subscribe to cosmic culture
and leave some comments on some recent
videos alright so we'll start off with
the leaked trailer 2 description then
we'll talk about why the trailer hasn't
come out yet according to these rumors
and then we'll talk about the run time
so a lot of people are posting this
online but take it with a grain of salt
because we really don't know if this is
true or not i will say i hope it is
because i believe this is how the second
trailer should be this was posted
anonymously online and the person says
the trailer is pretty much finished but
it's still being polished and it's in
the dubbing process right now they also
say it will release around november 15th
through the 17th but again take that
with a grain of salt that is in no way a
confirmation and the person says this is
not the order of the scenes in the
actual trailer but these are the scenes
that are going to be in the trailer
there's a few scenes from the first
trailer and some are a bit extended but
we will see a shot of peter at a
courtroom but we mostly see his face and
we don't see matt murdock that means
while he's in the courtroom they pretty
much just focus on him and you can't
really see anybody else around doesn't
mean that matt murdock isn't in the
movie i doubt they would put that in the
trailers it goes on to say all five
villains are shown green goblin doc ock
electro sandman and the lizard and these
are pretty much the villains that are
confirmed to be in the film there is not
going to be a sixth villain according to
some insiders i know some people are
disappointed about that i am too i just
feel like you were so close to the
sinister six you probably should have
went for it but then again i do have
trust in marvel studios and since
they're kind of running the whole thing
here i'm sure it's going to be great it
says we see a bit more of the fight with
doc ock at the bridge and this obviously
makes sense because a lot of the photos
that have been released recently have
been nothing but spider-man on that
bridge and that's the big part that's
known alfred molina came out way before
the first trailer was even shown and
said yeah i'm in the film i'm coming
back so he spoiled that a long time ago
so now they're just kind of leaning into
it going to show us a lot of doc ock a
lot of that scene with doc ock and
spidey on the bridge and it looks like
we're going to get even more of that in
the second trailer if this is true it
says some scenes from the alternate
first trailer are shown including a shot
with peter covered in green paint it
says peter fights electro now this is
interesting because i'm curious to see
if it's just peter kind of running away
from some lightning or if they actually
show jamie foxx as electro i mean they
showed out for molina as doc ock they
showed a pumpkin bomb even though they
didn't show the green goblin it would
make sense that they would show jamie
foxx especially because in the first
trailer it didn't really show any
electro at all yes it did show some
lightning but if you're not super
hardcore fans like we are you don't
really know what to look for and you
don't really know that that's electro
and it does seem like this specific
second trailer is going to focus more on
introducing some villains and really
talking about the plot which i think is
going to be based off of everything that
i've heard peter parker letting the
villains loose and trying to fight them
and get them back into doctor strange's
mystical magical prison so they can put
them back in their original dimension
universe reality whatever you want to
call it so if that's the main plot it
would make sense that the second trailer
would focus on these villains that are
loose it then goes on to say that the
creature that attacks peter in the first
trailer that many people thought was
venom is revealed to be the lizard we
actually see peter looking at him right
after being attacked and from what i've
seen i do believe it's the lizard
because one i don't think they would
just throw venom into a movie randomly
after all there is zero backstory
between venom and spider-man right now
and i would just hate if venom randomly
showed up and just hated peter for no
reason whatsoever but two a 4k trailer
came out and a bunch of people kind of
captured some stills and it does look
like it is lizard but i believe this
scene is when he's actually captured i
believe he's in doctor strange's prison
at this point and he goes to attack
peter but there's a barrier in between
them so he kind of just hits the barrier
then peter turns around and then he
stares at him and that's probably the
scene that we're going to get in the
second trailer this next part i find
rather interesting and i'll explain why
after this part says strange is shown a
bit more including a scene of ned
interacting with him i'm not really sure
how much doctor strange is going to be
involved with this film i think he's
going to play a big part in the
beginning but i think for the most part
it's going to be peter out there trying
to go get the villains but here's a big
rumor that i heard ned is actually going
to be the one to bring toby and andrew
to tom hall and spider-man in the film
he's not going to be responsible for
bringing them into the universe and to
the mcu but somehow he is the one that
manages to get the three of them to team
up that's just something i heard treat
it as a rumor for now it goes on to say
there's a shot of peter all bloody in
his far from home suit that is probably
the same battle as that empire magazine
photo and i would assume since they are
showing some other villains in this
trailer they'll probably show peter all
beat up the trailers need to make it
seem like peter is way over his head
with fighting all of these villains and
that he kind of can't handle it and that
he's going to have to overcome something
or meet up with some other people in
order to take them on it then says
there's a shot of peter at feast we see
the logo in the background talking to
somebody with a worried look it doesn't
show who he's talking to though now i
know when people hear this most people
will automatically think miles morales
and i really am wondering if they will
tease him in this movie i mean after all
he already does exist in the mcu prowler
was in the first spider-man movie
spider-man homecoming and he did mention
his nephew so i do wonder if this could
be a little tease for miles or if this
could simply be aunt mae that he's
talking to because she's working at
feast and the last thing that it says is
andrew and toby are teased but not shown
and i want to talk about this real quick
because this is apparently the reason
why we don't have the trailer yet marvel
studios and sony seem to be at a
disagreement on whether or not they
should show them in the trailer or not
according to the rumor kevin feige does
not want to show andrew garfield and
toby maguire in the trailer he wants
them to be revealed in the actual film
and not talk about them beforehand
however the rumor also says that sony
does want to show them in the trailer
they do want to tease them just a little
bit before the movie comes out and
according to this rumor this is why the
trailer has not been released yet
because they have not decided on whether
or not they're going to show the other
two spider-man in the trailer hopefully
we don't have to wait that much longer
to figure it out because hopefully the
trailer comes within a couple of weeks
from what i've heard it's not looking
like it's this week although this week
is almost over but it's also not looking
like it's next week but possibly the
week after that and of course if i hear
anything i'll let you know but the last
thing that i want to talk about today is
that the possible run time for spiderman
no way home could have been revealed
there's a very popular portuguese
website called ingreso.com it's
basically like fandango.com and the
twitter account spider-man brazil
noticed that spider-man no way home was
listed on the website and when you click
on spider-man no way home it gives a run
time of 2 hours and 39 minutes so if
this website is accurate that's how long
the movie is going to be and that's
pretty long it's not quite three hours
like avengers end game but it's pretty
dang long the eternals is 245 i think
and i thought that that was a really
good length i personally think that with
everything going on in this movie it
could easily be a three and a half four
hour movie but i am excited that it is
two hours and 39 minutes because that's
still pretty long so what i really want
to know from everybody is whether or not
you think they should show toby and
andrew in this trailer or not should
they reveal them in a trailer or reveal
them in the theater let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below don't forget to subscribe and like
the video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram twitter or tick
tock and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof